Do you ever get the feeling like you’re being watched?
The other day, I was thinking about buying
this blanket online. I put it in my cart,
but then kinda waffled 'cause it was expensive,
and then I got distracted and did something
else. I just received a personal
Facebook message from the company reminding
me that it's in my cart!
How did they do that? I don’t even use the
same email addresses for these accounts! Is Facebook listening
to me?
Don’t go getting fit for your tinfoil hat
just yet. There isn’t any hard evidence
that Facebook is surreptitiously accessing
your phone’s mic, and even if they could,
the volumes of data they’d have to analyze
to eavesdrop on just their American users
would be about 20 petabytes per day… 33
times more than their total daily data consumption.
Besides, online tracking technology is so
advanced these days, they don’t really need
to. You’re dropping bread crumbs everywhere
you go.
Imagine if you went to a shopping mall and
had an employee follow you around upselling
the entire time:
Don’t you just love that shirt? Give me
your email and I’ll give you $5 off right
now! Hey, remember that yoga mat you looked
at last week? Well guess what, 5 other people
just bought it and say it’s the best ever!
10% off if you buy it right now! Hey, don’t forget
it’s your mom’s birthday next week. She’d
love this hilarious coffee mug! Or maybe
this fancy candle? Three for the price of
one if you just use this code!
No one likes being badgered by an overly excited
employee. But that’s basically what’s
happening when you shop online. And it can
take a serious toll on our bank accounts.
So let’s get clear on what companies are
really doing and what we can do about it.
The main tactic that e-tailers use is called
Online Behavioral Advertising. It’s pretty
darn sophisticated and getting more so every
day. Here’s how it works: First, a website
will implant a small piece of data on your
computer known as a cookie. Sounds cute, but
this cookie comes with strings attached. It
tracks how you maneuver around a website.
What pages you click on, how long you hang
out there, what you search for, what you add
to your cart.
It then harvests this data and uses it to
build a profile. It tries to guess things
like your age, your income bracket, your likes
and dislikes all in hopes of serving you ads
that are the most likely to capture your attention.
As new parents, we do most of our shopping
online, which makes us prime targets. Julia
was recently served up an ad for baby-booties
that don’t slip off.
If you didn’t know, keeping socks or shoes
on babies’ feet is basically impossible,
so of course my attention was captured. I
clicked the link and wouldn’t ya know it...5
minutes later I was checking out. And now,
those dang shoes pop up on EVERY SITE I’M
ON! I feel like I can’t escape! Thanks,
cookies.
This is a textbook example of “re-targeting,”
Only 2% of users will become a customer on
their first visit, so a cookie’s job is
to quietly follow you around cyberspace, waiting
for the right time to invite you back to their
store.
If a retailer has gotten access to your contact
information like your email, you will also be
barraged with personalized ads and offers.
Amazon is the absolute king of this tactic.
Say you buy a yoga mat, they will assume you
probably need this awesome yoga shirt, oh
and you gotta have yoga blocks and what about
yoga socks?! These approaches are super effective.
A re-targeted ad is 70% more likely to become
a paying customer than a randomly served one.
Amazon is also famous for leveraging something
called “social proof,” our tendency to
copy the actions of others because we assume
they know more than we do. This is why 87%
of users report that they use customer reviews
to decide on a purchase. Of course, because
this is the internet, this has led to an entire
hidden economy of sellers paying people to
write fake reviews for their products. Amazon
claims that the percentage of reviews that
are fraudulent is “tiny,” but they don’t
really have much of an incentive to crack
down on them because the more good reviews,
the more sales. There are websites that will
analyze a product page and tell you how many
of the reviews are suspect, but the methods
these sites use are not proven to be 100%
accurate.
All this wouldn’t be so bad if going online
was something you did every once in a while.
But according to a recent Nielsen study, Americans
spend approximately 11 hours PER DAY staring
at screens. That’s like spending half your
life in a shopping mall. It’s no surprise
that one out of every three dollars of discretionary
spending is being spent online.
While avoiding online shopping altogether
probably isn’t realistic, there are things
we can do to minimize the creepy stalking
from retailers so we can shop more deliberately.
First, set up an email account for
your online shopping. That way, all the spam
and promotional offers won’t be clogging
your primary inbox.
Next, you can regularly delete cookies and
“un-remember” your credit card numbers
from your browser’s memory. I know, I know,
this will make online shopping less convenient
because you’ll have to keep re-entering
your info, but remember, we’re trying to
fight brainlessness and make purchasing as
intentional as possible. E-tailers want shopping
to be effortless, because they know that the
more steps involved, the more chances you’ll
have to realize that you don’t really need
those fancy yoga socks. If you’re not sure
how to do this, just google, "How to erase cookies in..." The name of your browser
And lastly, we strongly recommend setting
a hard cap for online expenditures by opening
a separate checking account or online wallet
that’s only for shopping online. Top it
off with how much you want to allow yourself
to spend per month, and when it’s empty,
well, you’ll just have to wait till next
month to get that that 4K Blu-Ray of The Matrix.
I admit it, I love seeing those packages show
up at my door as much as the next person,
but for most people, shopping online is a
luxury. The vast majority of necessities like
groceries and household supplies are still
purchased at brick and mortar stores.
E-tailers want us to treat online shopping
like a normal, habitual part of lives, but
any discretionary spending should still be a special,
deliberate decision. You probably can’t
ever get away from online advertising, but
you can at least be aware of how it’s trying
to influence your behavior.
And that’s our two cents!
Are there any other ways online advertisers are driving you crazy?
I'd love to hear about it in the comments.